foreign
they can't work at night like men can
because they have to be home with their
families
the Indian city of Ahmedabad is turning
to novel ways of protecting Women's
Health and livelihoods against extreme
temperatures
sells raw meat from a street cart but
soaring temperatures are making life
hard for the 56 year old Widow
um
when the Mercury Rises vulnerable women
like kunwar face a dilemma
stay home and lose a day's income or
Brave dangerous conditions to earn a
living extreme heat is
affecting women more than other groups
women's health is being affected by
extreme heat profoundly women's hands
are burned they have rashes 12 months
out of the year they have headaches they
have miscarriages they are experiencing
income loss because of these health
effects and other aspects of extreme
heat to their animals if they're farming
to their products when they're selling
in the market
the self-employed women's Association or
Seva is testing parametric insurance
that helps protect women when it's too
hot to work outside
the extreme heat income micro insurance
is a parametric insurance and that means
that it pays out when an event happens
and in this case the event is extreme
heat conditions
000 women are taking part in the pilot
providing a Lifeline to women like
kunwar
we've devised an insurance that when the
conditions are too dangerous to work
they receive a supplement for their
income to their bank accounts they also
have physical interventions like gloves
and tarps for their crops nighttime
solar lights and water coolers to keep
their water cool and safe
Seva members contribute a small amount
to a fund as they would with any
insurance product but it's a novel
concept for many of the women
one of the obstacles to having women
join the program is that it's brand new
one of the obstacles is communicating
what it is and then the other is sharing
the full value of the program and the
member understanding and willing to take
a chance on something new
foreign
is just one of a number of measures in
place to deal with the extreme heat here
in 2013 all metabod launched the first
heat action plan in a South Asian City
other initiatives include widespread
cool roofs in the slums early warning
systems and Hospital heat wards
here at one of ahmedabad's oldest
markets vegetables and flowers Wilt over
time colored fabrics and Plastics fade
again
greenhouse gas emissions from Cars power
plants and other human activities have
already made the planet 1.2 degrees
Celsius warmer than pre-industrial times
according to a 2018 scientific paper
global warming of 2 degrees Celsius
would result in a six-fold increase in
the number of heat waves in India but
the planet is currently on track to
exceed that making some of the hottest
regions virtually unlivable
thank you